everybody experiences that negative
self-talk it doesn't matter who you are
whether you're david goggins this is
where a lot of people get it wrong a lot
of people think that person whoever it
might be is must be made of something
else because
there's no way that they have the same
narrative internally as
i do and it's the same narrative
sometimes i'm on a 10 or 15k
run and sometimes you just feel like and
you want to stop it's exactly the same
narrative i know this is hard to
understand this is
the same narrative as when you're there
at 120 kilometers into a race
it's i want to stop these are the
reasons why that all makes sense
it's okay all of these things so all of
that will happen and
you know the listeners can experience
that on a 10k run or or it can be 120k
but it's just the same narrative
i'm a completely different person than
what i was when i started the whole
ultra conversation a completely
different year i look at things
differently i
i approach things differently i value
things differently
interesting everything everything
changed well that's a good place to
start
so what has changed you have done
multiple ultra events
what like and what's what's the impact
been on you in terms of races
and the first uh first bit the first big
one for me actually went
really badly and so myself and marcus
flew across to wales and we did a
80 kilometer uh run across the brecon
beacons
first time i've done anything like that
and it was a little bit last minute in
terms of deciding
that looks like fun let's have a crack
training was terrible for it in terms of
when i look back now
and and body kind of fell to pieces head
fell to pieces
and it was it was one of those
situations we've all been through like
you you have to kind of hit the bottom
before you can start to realize
where you want to go and you look back
on that later in life and you realize
that's exactly what needed to happen for
me to then sort of evolve from there so
that that didn't go well um like i said
what's not well no i just um
just body broke down which is fine i
mean that happens if you haven't trained
for something then
obviously you can't expect to get
through very well finished it but like
week head complaining just moaning about
[ __ ]
i'm i'm done with this just like
as i suppose you'd expect somebody that
hasn't worked on any form of mental
strength or
or tried to sort of build that side of
themselves up
you you fall to pieces when you get into
an environment like that when you're
however many hours we were in so that
was the first experience
and it haunted me it really stuck in my
head gonna say a lot of people might
have just turned back after that
yeah well to be honest it was one of
those situations where i knew i know
myself well enough to know that that was
going to sit with me for a long time
and it sat with me for a while and i
realized that um
i had to do something bigger and i had
to do something
fairly soon to fix that and it was it's
gambling right you're like
i'm gonna go bigger and if this is
called the sunk cost fallacy yeah
there it is on the casino floor yeah
exactly right so
let's throw more money good money after
bad money um but
it's a risk right because you're playing
with your own mental space then you're
like if this works out
i'm i'm good again but if it doesn't
work out i've had two losses here
and they're getting bigger so you know
it's just oh it's the same as gambling
like good analogy
so the next thing we signed up for was
marathon disabled which was 250
kilometers across the sahara desert
i'm not sure if marcus was chatting
about that that earlier and then
that was the first big thing that was
when we talked about reborn and the
entire change of mindset
i i sat on a charter flight out of
gatwick into
into morocco and i was nervous as hell i
was i looked around the only people on
the flight were were those doing the
the marathon to some and and you you see
guys with like
iron man tattoos all over them just like
you're just like elite athletes extreme
people and i'm just sat there thinking
[ __ ] what am i doing on this flight
i'm a guy who complained about racing
work yeah last last time
yeah last time i i tried this i it just
fell to pieces and i
literally i sat there and i wrote a few
notes on a piece of paper
and it was they were behavioral goals it
was yes it was finished yes don't die
um but then it was you know inspire
others to finish
so and another one we don't complain
once
so i was putting myself i was
challenging myself to the extent that
it wasn't just about you need to try and
finish this race it was going
far beyond that to say you're not going
to utter a single complaint
a single word that's negative for eight
days
on what the discovery channel has termed
the toughest foot race on earth
and you're going to inspire other people
to finish so
which was so far removed from where i'd
been in the previous race
that that was the challenge i was trying
to set myself to to to really push
limits and boundaries and it was that it
was look it was sitting on the flight
out afterwards
yet not necessarily having a physical
medal or anything like that but i still
had that dirty
half torn piece of paper that i kept
with me the whole time and to be able to
look down at each of those things and
say
i achieved that and that was that was a
real defining moment or a pivotal moment
in terms of
my journey in terms of improving mindset
and headspace
and it went from there really um i did
the the marathon to solve again
this time down in peru so another 250k
self-supported you carry everything on
your back and they only give you water
for
for six days everything else you're
carrying with you and you're running
through sound so
you can imagine i'll get into all the
details but um you can imagine what
that's um what that's like
and then the most recent one which was a
while back now um
which was the 137 kilometer down across
the
hatter mountain range in oman the
borders between uae and oman
and that was that was that was a whole
different ball game the 250 across the
sahara sounds crazy but
you break that down into 30 to 40k a day
apart from on the fourth day we did 92
kilometers something like that which was
pretty intense
on on the fourth day of running um
because you're basically sleeping on the
floor for
five days at that point so you can
imagine like there's no showers there's
no nothing it's it's in a good way
yeah it's not it's not the best um but
the one in dan and oman was a completely
ball game that was uh
uh it was it was single single leg it's
137k straight through
and the combined elevation of that race
was 8 thousand meters
and to put that into context you know
everest is eight thousand eight hundred
so that was a different ballgame how
long did nothing
42 hours straight without sleep without
sleep
i was awake for 56 hours so yeah that
was a
different ball game what is it like to
be awake for that long with physical
exertion
you hallucinate you you start to have
out-of-body experiences and it's not
just um
that sounds dramatic but that's that's
literally what happened so like
during the second night we started at 7
00 p.m so you run through the night
you start to feel a little bit like all
over the place as the sun's coming up
because you're still going
then you go through all the heat of the
day in the mountains then you go through
sunset again when your body is starting
to tell itself it needs to sleep because
of your circadian
rhythm as you well know um and then you
you're still going and then you're going
through that next night now your body's
like
hold on a second we've been through two
of these nights and you're still not in
bed
what's going on um so they start you
know your body starts to do certain
things to try and get you to stop you
have all the logical conversations
with yourself around why it's okay to
stop and why you should stop and
that pain is actually or you don't know
what that could be that could be
something really bad
all this negative self-talk all of the
reasons logical reasons is
why you should stop um and then you
start to hallucinate
and that's a really interesting space so
the second night from around about
um i'd say midnight to about 4 a.m i
went only went through one checkpoint
and i was completely on my own because
they'd had
i think it was 50 to 60 percent of the
race had dropped out by that point
um it was the first time they'd ever run
that race i don't think anybody realized
how horrific it was going to be um
national geographic did a a whole
documentary on on the race
and it's only been run once at that
length or so they did it one more time
two years later
but but that's it and it's it's it's the
most ridiculous thing
we didn't realize right i mean we're
talking
the distance is almost irrelevant the
137k because people can only
conceptualize that on a road
and that sounds pretty crazy it's 137
kilometers on the road it sounds pretty
ridiculous
but when you put in to context of 8 000
meters of elevation
that means you're talking 1.2 kilometer
down
gorgeous so you get to the edge of a
gorge you've got to go
two kilometers as a crow flies but
you've got to go 1.2 kilometers down
into this gorge
and 1.2 kilometers back up you go for 5k
you hit another one so you you're
talking it takes you six hours to go the
space of
six kilometers sometimes or even longer
like it's
we were clipped in with carabiners
climbing up cliff faces
as part of this race and it was the most
ridiculous thing like we got
the 120k mark there was a checkpoint
that i came into
blown to pieces like you know
hallucinating through the night
um you know eyes gone legs gone just in
in bits
and that was 100 so that was 120
kilometers
the next three kilometers from 120 k
was straight vertical 1.2 kilometers
straight up that we were scrambling
poles had to go away
and and we were scrambling with like
literally hands like climbing
like scrambling up a cliff face and we
were we i mean i'd been awake
i don't know why i say we because i was
on my own but
me and the hallucinations in my head had
been awake for ages it was just next
level and then you know it was uh
it was scary as hell because you know
during the day it was 32 34 which living
in the middle east
that's okay you can we trained for that
but it was at night
um winds like howling and it was between
six and eight degrees
so the the the difference you know you
you know what it's like you just start
to get tired you start to get cold
now we're not used to the cold in the
middle east either so now you're on a
cliff face it's blowing it's pitch black
it's three in the morning you're
hallucinating
you're trying to scramble you've got 120
kilometers in your legs
and and you i mean you barely know what
day it is so you just keep trying to
move
so that was um i suppose that was a
culmination in my personal journey of
that first race in in wales in abigail
venue where i just fell to pieces on an
atk
wasn't flat it was the breaking beacons
but it was pretty sedentary walk in the
past
yeah this afternoon then you end up with
that thing and it was just like
you know finishing it was was just about
survival and it was um it was
it was yeah it was an interesting place
you spoke about the logical
rational reasons to stop that your brain
throws up
and i'm fascinated by those because as
someone who's never done an endurance
race like that
yeah um i but exercises a lot everybody
knows what it feels like
to hear that voice yeah that's a that's
a twinge that's
that's where you injured yourself three
years ago that might be coming back
what do you what is going through your
head how do you deal with that negative
self-talk and that doubt
look it's a really good question and um
one thing i really want to drive home
for listeners to take away from this is
that
everybody experiences that negative
self-talk it doesn't matter who you are
whether you're david goggins whether you
know it doesn't matter who you are
and and this is the this is where a lot
of people get it wrong a lot of people
think
they're that that person whoever it
might be is must be made of something
else because
there's no way that they have the same
narrative internally as
as i do and it's the same narrative
sometime i'm on a 10 or 15k
run and sometimes you just feel like
[ __ ] and you and you want to stop
it's exactly the same narrative i know
this is hard to understand it's
the same narrative as when you're there
at 120 kilometers into a race
it's i want to stop these are the
reasons why that all makes sense
it's okay all of these things so all of
that will happen and
you know the listeners can experience
that on a 10k run or or it can be 120k
it's just the same narrative and it's
understanding that it's okay to have
that negative self talk accept it
don't don't think you're a lesser person
because something in the back of your
mind
is telling you that you should stop when
you're uncomfortable at the end of the
day our brain is is programmed to
protect us
that's what it does throughout time it
protects us so
when you're putting your body through
excessive strain your brain's job
is to stop you from doing it your
brain's job is not to push you harder
your brain's job is to keep you with
inside your comfort zone in very
inventive ways you know inventive ways
it's crafty bugger
so you've got you've got to accept the
fact that that's going to happen
and and it's it's accepting that
narrative and then and then allowing
um allowing yourself to it's not
allowing yourself
bringing different tools into play to to
get through that and get past that
first thing is acceptance of that
narrative and just being like cool
i i hear you i'm not going to listen to
you but i hear you it's okay
and then it's also you know there's all
sorts of tricks that you can like you
start going jedi mind tricks on yourself
and you start thinking right well
you know there's internal motivation
there's external motivation and
external motivation can be okay but when
i get to the end of this race
and i'm sat down with my support crew
you know my wife my girlfriend my coach
whoever it might be
external motivation is like what
conversation do you want to be having
with them
oh these are all the 15 reasons why i
dropped out of this race and i didn't
feel so good
so there's your external motivation
right there if you can visualize that
then straight away you're going to be
like no i'm not having that conversation
no i'm going to keep going i'm not
having that comment that's the external
side of it right
the internal side of it and there's
always a the ratio can can change
depending on a number of things
but the internal side of it has got to
be like why am i actually
doing this if you're going to put
yourself through a very difficult
situation you need to know why
beforehand
and the reason being is because it's
inevitably going to get very difficult
at some point
and if you don't have a reason why
you're doing it that's valid
then what are you going to do you're
going to stop right
you're going to pull out of it because
why am i even here i don't understand
why i'm here
in the same way maybe an understandable
example of this you sign up for your
first marathon
scares the [ __ ] out of you you wake up
at five o'clock in the morning you know
exactly why you're waking up at five
o'clock in the morning
if you hadn't signed up for the marathon
and i said wake up and i mean you
probably do that anyway but
if i said if you weren't an athlete they
said right wake up tomorrow morning at 5
a.m and go for a run
cool okay i'm motivated day three what
are you doing wake up at 5am you're like
what the hell
am i doing like [ __ ] it i'm not doing
that there's no reason to do it but if
you signed up for a marathon
and you're actually a bit worried about
completing it and you've got sponsorship
and you've got all these things
you now have both internal and external
motivation
for for getting through that so it's
understanding
that that narrative internally and
playing those those jedi mind tricks on
yourself to get you through to complete
the run or to get up in the morning or
whatever it is that that's causing you
that pain at the time what
was the transformation that you saw in
yourself pre-endurance time and
post-endurance tom as a
day-to-day um not feeling sorry for
myself about anything
so not feeling that let's say you're in
a negative situation that's related to
business
to life break up with a in a
relationship whether it be a
that whether it be a work situation not
feeling sorry for myself in terms of
this is happening to me
the conversation myself is this is
happening and then how am i dealing with
it
not this is happening to me so for
example if i put it into a business
situation if we lose a contract for
for whatever reason it's objectively
looking at it and understanding
why if somebody does wrong by you
can sit back and say okay well you can
take that victim's mindset of saying
right
why are all these things happening to me
whoever tied me
and and you can sit in that little pool
of self-pity for as long as you like
that's not going to get you anywhere or
you can understand that this is what's
happening
how do i deal with it 2020 is a prime
example we've as we've already said it's
sub-optimal years you're very well put
and
as we look at that there's a lot of
people and and i'm very conscious
everyone's going through a different
experience with this right
for some people it's devastating for
other people it's it's moving in their
direction and there's a whole range in
between so
certainly not being flippant to that
fact at all but also understanding that
there is a
there is a way of dealing with this from
a mindset perspective
that will either benefit you or will not
help you in any which way and that's
understanding that it's happening
and the dynamics have changed so
therefore it's just how you react to it
if it's a negative if it's affecting
affecting you and your
whatever your scenario is negatively it
just is what it is
and it's now understanding okay well if
this is the new set of scenarios i have
to deal with how am i navigating it
or you sit at home and you're like this
isn't my fault look at the world
uh i'm reading i'm reading the news
every day and the whole world's melting
and i can't possibly
find a single positive story in this and
i can't positively
possibly um achieve any of my goals or i
can't think of new goals to set
and you know we i'm sure we all know
people that are that are sitting in that
space
and just saying that none of this is my
fault therefore i can't do anything
about it
and that and that's the key difference
it's the mindset of like
is it is it your fault or is it your
responsibility like it's not your fault
that the world is melting down but it is
your responsibility to do something
about it
whether that be for you personally
whether that be through for your
business whether it be through
your family or whatever it is like
that's your responsibility right
um and i suppose that's the mindset
shift of
going back to a run everything that you
know all hell's breaking loose
your knees gone you've your waters run
out
it's just a different set of scenarios
and you can't constantly play the
victims mindset of this is happening to
me therefore
i give up it's just a different set of
scenarios that you've got to approach
and that endurance experience is then
transitioned across for you into
everyday life yeah massively massively
so same with with you know whether it be
work whether it be personal
relationships all of these things
you just approach it that this is a a
changing set of scenarios
if it's a mistake that you've made own
the mistake you know none of us are
perfect whether it be business
whether it be fitness whether it be
personal we've all got our flaws
so own any mistakes that you make but
just try and make a positive
impact wherever you can for yourself and
for you know for the scenario that
you're trying to affect whether that be
business or personal
i was reading the almanac of naval
ravikant again okay the other day
and in that he says you are born
a set of stimulus occurs and then you
die okay
how you choose to respond is completely
up to you perfect
perfect and it's so simple like i wish
i'd said that rather than the last 15
minutes
that was much more insightful right
that's one of the problems that i have
i'm unsure how i feel about this pithy
aphorism
maxim world i like the fact that you can
deliver an entire concept and maybe
everyone that's listening when they
think about you're born you
receive some stimulus and you pass away
how you choose responds up to you maybe
that will be what they take and think
ah that tells me all about the lessons
that tom gave me in that
element i like it in another element it
can become quite a
sort of masturbatory um showy game
of who can summarize the site the most
sort of cerebral cool quote
um but yeah they're important though i
think so
i think i think that there must be
little mantras that we keep
telling ourselves and that's something
that i asked your good buddy marcus
smith earlier on today
is there anything that you keep in your
mind
as you're going through particularly
painful sections of these events is
there something you go back to a little
mantra
um
to be honest it's in in terms of
terminology it's not there's not one
single mantra it's just understanding
that
the concept is very well put by itself
just then in terms of
i don't want to i don't want to i don't
live with regret at the end of the day
and and that's what it that's what it
comes down to it's like you know forgive
yourself for your flaws
and but if it's coming down if you're
talking specifically about a race it's
just understanding why you're there it's
just understanding that um
that you don't want to be looking back
on this and that you failed and that
drives me in business that drives me in
in everything and that's an approach to
life
you as you've just suggested there have
got a lot of irons in the fire
and extreme endurance events you've also
is it
46th fastest growing
company in the like unbelievably quick
growing company which has got multiple
offices all across
this area of the world and family life
and then also just trying to exist as a
human
how do you balance all of those things
i and a lot of the people that are
listening
will think like i couldn't do one of
those things
full time and somehow this guy is have
you got the cheat code to fit 36 hours
into a day
you know is there is there a
doppelganger that you've got like a
secret
identical twin that you're not telling
us about yeah look it's um
there's a number of things mate i mean
look it's it's
it's certainly putting the hours in um
you know over the years it's
they say you've got to you've got to
choose your pain right in terms of
what do you want out of life um anything
that you
choose any direction you choose to go in
uh comes with um
pros and cons in terms of
we're good with the um so in terms of
direction you want to go in with life
right if you choose to set a goal that
comes with
uh it comes along with um different
types of pain so
what can that look like if we if we're
talking in this context
i've missed so many social engagements
i've let friendships sort of um fizzle
out
i know far less people than i than i
used to
um but i'm okay with that as well
because i'm very focused in terms of
where i'm going and what i want to
achieve out of life
and what i'm trying to get to so it just
comes down to prioritizing
a lot of things you know it's it's
trying to be as organized as possible
but like i'm certainly not the most
organized person
people probably think i've got an agenda
for everything i don't um
and and it's it's funny i have
conversations with people and people
think that
i must have everything like covered and
crossed and teased t's crossed and
and and eyes dotted and the truth is i
don't like
um but i do put the hours in i do work
through the weekends and i do have a i
suppose an outlook on life as we touched
on earlier when
we first arrived and we're talking about
this and it's it's understanding that
that all of it just fits into
into life and it's easy to say when when
you own the company and you know whether
you're working or whether you're not
working it's all kind of the same thing
it's just
i have a goal with the business and and
i want to get there and that doesn't fit
into a nine to five
sometimes i'm sat one o'clock in the
morning writing ideas down and sometimes
i'm
off running for three hours in a day you
know it's it just depends what's on that
day the agenda
evolves um do you pity people
who haven't found this level of passion
in their life
pity would be the wrong the wrong term i
do um
i do feel that even like close friends
i feel that there's there's a lot of
opportunity for them to grow into that
space
you know i think it's really important
that people find their passions i've
been lucky to find it in a number of
different ways
and my personal relationship with my
wife um my business
and and running and i absolutely love
all of those things and
and to be able to explore all of them to
the to the extremes to go from meeting
someone to getting married from
um from running as for a bit of fun to
exploring
you know places in the sahara desert
that very few people will ever visit
to being able to have the opportunity to
grow a business like this and it's
um i know that i'm very fortunate but i
know it's also because i've focused on
these things
and none of these things have just
happened
it's been a conscious focus and a
constant effort to try and to try and
drive that and that and that comes and
said go back to the
choose your pain things like if you're
if you're going to be
really focused on something and one way
to explain it is that
look you can't you can't be half in on
on everything because you that just
results in in average right so if
people have this concept of a balanced
life and if you try and
remain balanced with all of these things
what actually happens is you you hit a
median level
across all of them if you think of them
on a on a let's say a table chart
you only hit median level and everything
so my focus and my kind of concept and
this isn't new but it's certainly
something i followed for a long time is
this constant level of
imbalance so micro imbalance for macro
balance so if you look at my life across
the board i'm very happy with a
relationship
with the business and i enjoy my
passions and enjoy my friends
but at a certain time i'm completely
imbalanced
so if i'm gearing up for a long race i
you won't get hold of me because i'm
either running or i'm working
if there's a huge thing going on at work
and when you're opening a new office or
moving a country or
something something that's happening i'm
all in on that and i you know i won't be
seen so much around the running track
but then and then sometimes you know if
i'm just getting married or something
right
as you do you're all in on that and then
you know so it's it's
it's focusing on whatever the goal is in
a certain time frame going all
in in that space to try and be the best
version of yourself in that space so
like with with running you can only get
to be
having the capacity to run for 40 odd
hours and you know run ultramarathons
if you're purely focused on that but the
thing that i see is that
the community i spend time with i'm not
talking in a fight community
but let's say when we go to those races
the only people there are like
absolute uber running geeks right
they're all in it's their entire life
but i'll step into that scenario and
then i'll step out of it and then i'll
go into the business space
where there's business owners and and
business leaders that that's all they do
for like 90 of their life
and they really struggle with any form
of fitness they really struggle with
with balancing anything and then there's
it's that's easier to quantify than
their personal relationship but you can
see
you can see that what i try and do is
find the time and dedicate the time to
be
the best i can in this space but then
pull back from it i can't be
i can't have the capacity to run an
ultra marathon all year
unless that's all i did so i go in and i
go out and that's how i try and achieve
as much as i can in a certain space
pull back from it focus on a different
space and then maybe go back to that a
few months later
so macro balance but micro very much
imbalanced
is that done in advance do you look at
your year is this very is it a very
structured thing
you can't just decide to run an ultra
marathon tomorrow but similarly
there's a lot of inputs that we don't
have control over
the new catastrophe that inevitably
occurs at work
the injury that throws you yeah training
schedule out
the argument you have with your misses
etc etc
what is the process that you go through
to kind of
set that out because it sounds fantastic
everyone that's listening should have
listened to the episode they did with
greg mcewen on essentialism
focus on the vital few not the trivial
many where is the
single highest point of contribution
that you can have in your life
and go for that naval ravican uh become
the best in the world of what you do
continue to redefine what you do until
it's true okay
um and all of these different things
take us to the same place which is
deep focused work single task focus
multitasking is [ __ ] you can't do
multiple things at once
and even if you try to spread that out
really across month
periods you can't open the new office
whilst you train for the ultra marathon
it's just not going to happen
yeah but implementing that actually
taking it from it being a concept that
everybody can really understand
cerebrally
and getting it into their life is this a
pre-commitment are you looking at
quarters and thinking right okay
i have this event coming up i have this
office opening coming up i'm going to do
this
and i'm going to allow and notice the
discomfort
from knowing that my fitness is dropping
off or from knowing that i'm gonna have
to miss some emails
or knowing that me and my wife are maybe
gonna have a more strange relationship
because of this focus self-wear is that
is that something that you have to
plan in advance yeah look really good
question i mean it's it's something that
i
that i do plan i wouldn't i wouldn't say
that there's a there anything
that's written down no there's not but
it's there are certain
um pillars going back to your points
there a race
the race date is the race date right if
you want to run that race and you've
signed up for it in six months then
that dictates a lot of the training
program already um
but also you can choose different races
to to do throughout the year based on
what else is going on in life so there's
there's there's a focus in terms of
what does the year look like when is a
good time
for us to be well when is a good time
for me to be training when is a good
time
to be racing and what's going on in in
business
and have that rough schedule to say
right these are the things and stuff
but sometimes it'll go wrong but you
have to have that that approximate
structure
but then sometimes i'll have to bail on
a race four weeks before
the race even if i've done three months
of training for it because i realized
that
right now the priority is something
going on in business we might have
won a big account or lost a big account
or you know
whatever whatever happens you know it's
chaos control chaos every day so
um with that side of things like that
has to take priority i don't put myself
in my running over
business because i'm beholden to 100
people at the agency
like my job is to look after them so if
i'm being selfish and going off and
doing ultras
that can't be at their detriment and so
that's that's
always a bit of a challenge uh my wife
is amazing so she always
you know she she gives me the the
freedom and the space to do
as i want to when it comes to all that
side of things um but but yeah sometimes
you just have to pull the plug
and refocus so it's always just constant
reprioritizing of what's in front of you
but they should be built on some sort of
a structure even if it's just in your
head
because if you don't have any goals how
are you going to achieve anything
like i said it's in business we sit down
at the start of the year
and we structure or at the end of the
previous year we structure this is what
we want to do next year financial plans
um goal setting right we want to open a
new territory whatever that might be
and that's a very structured process
because that's what's needed that then
gets
assimilated through the business senior
management buy into that this is what
each of them need to do in order to
achieve that wider goal
so that's all very very structured
there's an element that you should take
from that understanding
into your personal life to say okay if i
want to
whatever it is if i want to run a
marathon this year if i want to do x y
or z lose 50 pounds
whatever it is get a partner yeah start
there we go so if you want to if you
want to
get a partner for example and you might
have been meeting the wrong people
you're probably going to the wrong
places
so you know how these things don't just
happen a business doesn't just build
itself a marathon doesn't run itself and
you know finding a partner sometimes you
can be lucky but quite often you've
actually got to start to think about it
especially as we get a little bit older
we're not meeting the hundreds of people
that we used to because we're not going
out as much
you have to be a little bit more
considerate of being like okay well if i
want to meet the right people
where am i going to put myself into the
situations of hopefully meeting those
people so
everything needs to be thought through
to an extent and then life happens right
so
then you've got to roll with the punches
sometimes sometimes that serendipity and
it all works out and it's amazing and
you're like wow i could never have
scripted it
and other times the [ __ ] hits the fan
and you've got to deal with a new set of
scenarios as we discussed earlier
but at least have some sort of structure
because if you don't
what are you doing just you're just
bouncing off the walls you know what
i've just thought of there which would
be a really cool thing to do and i'm
going to maybe suggest to some of my
buddies that we might do it this year
would be to have an agm on your life
that's great at the end of the year yeah
and do it you know around about
christmas time when everyone's back home
yeah how was your year man what went
well you know present to the board
like the floor is yours tom you know
step up and tell us
what did you what did well what did
badly what do you wish you could have
improved on yeah
and what your goals for next year what
do we all want to achieve next year how
can we help how can oh
you want to do that ultra thing well
actually i happen to have two complete
psychopaths in
dubai that i'm buddies with who can tell
you about the best training plan or this
thing
or you want to start a creative agency
don't happen to have an amazing
videographer whatever it might be yeah i
think that would be a really cool thing
to do
and one of the issues that i have and
many people may do as well
those of us that like being
self-sufficient often get
stuck in roots more than i think people
who are pulled out by other stimulus so
the advantage of having the agm is that
you will get that different input
we all know what we think it's very rare
that i actually have a new thought i
think that
neuroscience suggests that 90 of the
thoughts that you had today
are the same as you had yesterday okay
which actually means that
existing in your mind is a lot like
being trapped by the most boring
repetitive captor in history yeah um
and thinking about that makes you
realize that learning's a very slow
process
ten percent of the thoughts that you
have the different ones from yesterday
compound that over a year is i don't
actually spend that much time thinking
of new stuff still the same traumas that
i had from when i was
in school it's still the same fears that
i used to have from when i was at uni
and all that stuff
um yeah i think that the influence of
people like that could be a real
i think it would be really powerful and
no that's an interesting point about the
about the um the concepts and the
thoughts being so similar i think that's
why it's so important to to read to
listen to podcasts to
to start to expand your and i suppose
level of
content consumption that pulls you in
those different ways because you're
right
if you're self-sufficient mentally and
when you set your life up to be like i'm
cool as i am i've got everything i need
et cetera et cetera and you're not going
to get pulled in all of those different
directions and all the different
stimulus is going to affect you so much
so
as you said you can get stuck in a rut
and if you're constantly thinking about
trying to solve every problem yourself
you're only going to get so far with
that right we all need support we all
need help
um and to succeed it's always a group
effort and no matter who it is
no matter how how single focused they
are no matter how
that how much they seem like they've
done everything themselves it's always a
team effort because
they've had support from someone along
the way and i think going back to your
point about the agm i actually used
to do something with with marcus another
friend and another friend of mine
a few years ago when we were all kind of
coming up and we'd have monthly sessions
where
each of us each um each time it was
another person's focus so
let's say we meet on wednesday this is
this is your
your um your meeting basically you would
send out a brief
to us it was all written up we had
documentation for it we would read it
what's the scenario what's the problem
you're facing
what are your challenges and we would
then think about it when we come to the
meeting we discuss it we're all prepped
i have solutions yeah and we
just would support i can help with this
i can help with that and
so i think look for listeners as well i
mean you know you i think you've always
got to
audit the people that you're spending
most of your time with what we've all
heard the
you're the fifth person and etc etc so
the people you're spending the most time
with the most important group of people
and as we get
as we get older it starts to change it
starts to evolve it has to be a
conscious decision
you can't just be friends with someone
because you're friends with them at
school
if they're if that friendship's no
longer serving you then
you can still obviously be acquaintances
to be friends with them but they
shouldn't be in your
in your circle of five people if you're
not helping them grow and they're not
helping you grow
like you that you have to be supporting
each other and i think it's really
important to
to understand who those people that you
have around you that you're learning
from
and how you're supporting them and how
they're going to support you so
if you create that environment with this
agm with the four or five or six people
that you've got in your head
annual growth meeting there you go
annual growth meeting there you go
perfect we've nailed it yeah but it's
it's a super important concept if you've
got those people in your life you're
lucky
right unfortunately a lot of people that
are going to be listening might be
thinking wow i'm thinking about the
people i hang out with every day
they don't really have my agent is going
to be a board meeting of me in the class
yeah
yeah so it's super important if you
can't think of people to put on that
board
let's say in this concept that we're
talking about now then you need to start
to think about that
because that will have such a
significant effect
on your future that you need to start
thinking about it and thinking okay i
need to spend time with
people like that that will make me think
that make me feel good about myself
that will challenge me that will allow
me to grow that will push me to grow
that's going to be one of the single
biggest that in your own mindset
going to be the biggest factors in
determining your success where do you
see
people around you going wrong the most
with motivation
and with staying on track sure victim
mindset
all the time and it it it blows my mind
that it frustrates the [ __ ] out of me
it's people feeling sorry for themselves
thinking that
you know everything's happening to them
that life is happening to them
um not and it's not happening because of
them they're not actually
taking those steps forward they're
they're they're seeing what's happening
they're saying hands up i give up this
isn't my fault i'm allowed to quit
because
of these things that have happened and
it's that going back to that is it your
fault or is your responsibility
it's going back to that thought process
and it's that that frustrates me at the
end of the day
um it's people not taking ownership of
whatever that problem is
and it's it's very easy it's very easy
to be negative right
there's a there's a thousand reasons as
to why i wonder why you can't achieve
what you want to achieve
there's there's always so many reasons
as to that you can point to
and because we all have stressful lives
right we've all got we all none of us
have enough time
none of us um have all the resources
that we want whether that be financial
or otherwise
um so it's it's it's that mindset of
of saying i don't have enough i don't
have enough time i don't have enough
whatever
and to achieve what i want to achieve
and because of all these scenarios
and these things that i have no impact
on i therefore can't achieve x y or z
and that too honestly it frustrates the
[ __ ] out of me
that point of people realizing
leaning into that discomfort and
actually thinking
what's the next step trying to get over
the inertia
of noticing there's something wrong is
it for you
is your solution not looking to have
regrets
is it an aggression like leaning into
discomfort
is it a i'm grateful to be here
my sort of mindful acceptance you
understand there's multiple different
ways
that people could get over that because
as you said already
everybody feels like that like why is
this occurring that
thought no it pops up it's how you deal
with that and then move forward what's
your
sort of personal strategy with that look
i mean for
for me it's it's just yeah i mean
honestly it goes back to that that same
thought process around
around feeling sorry for yourself or not
it's just them you know how do you get
yourself out of that right how do you
focus on moving forward how do you keep
how do you keep challenging yourself how
do you keep wanting to grow i mean for
me
um there's a few i mean you touched on
something before we start the podcast
actually about um
around leadership right so 2020 has been
a challenge for leadership
in a number of different areas now as
you can imagine without me going into
all the details
if you're dealing with 100 people that i
look after in the agency that are
remote working now so that that was one
thing everyone come together
right as of 48 hours time no one's
coming back to the office
everyone's going remote so think of the
operational challenges because
the clients don't give two shits whether
you're in the office or whether you're
at home like they want the work they've
got deliverables are deliverable yeah
and if you're late you're late so like
that you know that that was a challenge
anyway just
navigating that side of it but yeah
you're right when i'm having clients
phoning up and saying oh we've got to
put this on hold because
xyz or our funding's been pulled by the
government so you know we've got to
go to stop this contract and all this
chaos on one side
but yet you've got to be a cheerleader
to the entire team on
on the other side and be like you know
we're in this together and we're going
to drive through them and run through
wars together and
trying to get everyone motivated to
really pull them together and really
build the culture within the agency
now that's that's a real challenge and
you know at multiple times whether it be
that scenario of like you've got to lean
into that comfort you have to lean into
that
that
that pain and that is how
you grow that is what a leader does and
so you can have these you can have this
internal dialogue
and this is often this is one that's
really worked well for me
is imagining what the ideal leader would
do
so don't put yourself in the situation
at this point let's say okay x has
happened
you happen to be the leader of this
scenario whether it be your business
whether it be your team
whether it be you know whatever your
scenario is you're the leader in this
particular
scenario x has happened and it's and
it's bad
now you you should look at that this is
how i do i look at it and be like okay
let's remove
myself from this remove the emotion from
it and look at it and be like if i was
reading about this in a book
what would the ideal leader do how would
they
behave how would they act how would they
engage with their team how would they
engage with
whatever it is that's the challenge and
i build that little framework and
sometimes this entire conversation can
happen in my head in
one minute before i whilst i go quiet
figure it out
and then and then act or it can you
might have a bit more time i have a few
days to
understand what's happened and work out
what you're going to do next so it's
understanding taking the emotion out of
it
figuring out what that blueprint looks
like and then putting yourself back into
it and saying
this is what i have to do so it's all
like you create
the blueprint of what you need to do
next you create your plan in your head
and then you say but i'm the leader in
this scenario so i have to do these
things
i have to be the one that stands up and
puts my hand up and say actually
this is a scenario and it could be i
mean we're talking about
often when it's a particularly
uncomfortable situation you might not
know how to deal with it it could be
something at work that that's happening
between two people it can be
um a social situation within work but
let's say a worldwide social movement
and you're like
how do i engage with what's going on in
the world
and relate it to my team and be the
figurehead for it and
do i bring everyone together to discuss
this or do we pretend like it's not
happening
how should we do it so again going back
to i sit on my own
i think about what would the ideal
leader do here and then i try and do it
and i try and emulate that so
and that's mostly leaning into
uncomfortable things so if you have that
mindset
that often will dictate because you've
already made the decision to yourself
i'm going to always try and do that once
i've come up with a plan i'm the guy
that's going to do it
so constantly doing that you remove the
choice
of saying oh do i feel like this do i
not feel like this because nine times
out of ten if it's worth doing you don't
feel like doing it
but you you look back on it and you
think [ __ ] i'm really glad i did that
and someone else is there going that was
a really good move that was the decision
to make
yes there's a few things we've been
through recently
that tie in with this the third party
perspective as it's called which is a
mental model that
doesn't take your side or the opposite
side it imagines you as a third person
uh there's a famous joe rogan video for
on it called be the hero of your own
story okay
he says imagine that your life is a
movie and the movie starts now
and the heroes downtrodden and
overweight and depressed and yeah like
doesn't have a partner he's lonely like
what would the hero do
like you're that guy do that now yeah
you can be that hero right now
and then uh james clear talks about
identity based change
so the way that james gets people to
change their habits
especially difficult and ingrained ones
is he gets you to ask
what would the person i want to be do in
this situation
so rather than being a smoker that's
trying to quit smoking it's
i don't smoke i'm not a smoker what
would not a smoker do
right now not a smoker wouldn't have a
cigarette so
not to smoke a toma not to smoke a chris
wouldn't do it
decision made it does help us to cut
through
i've been fascinated this year thinking
about just how much noise
our brains create and that having these
very very simple heuristics george
mcgill my good buddy who was on the show
yesterday
said elon musk every decision he makes
there's one rule one heuristic that he
follows will this
get the human race closer to mars
amazing
jeff bezos amazon one rule does this
improve the customer's experience
that's it and when you run all of the
noise all of that and you think these
guys must have
such a complex decision tree of what it
is that they're doing it's like no no
the two two of the most famous
entrepreneur innovators on the planet
are relying on a rule each to guide
everything they do business and personal
life
and trying to bring it back to that
simplicity and this
goes back to the maxim aphorist stuff
that we were talking about earlier on
having a little mantra having these
small pithy quotes and and
concepts that you can distill down to
rely on actually help to remind us that
all of the
the chaos that's going on can actually
be simplified down
yeah look very much so when it comes
down you know what you said there about
elon musk
and and bezos is it's that comes that
simplicity
comes from a goal and that goal is so
well defined
in both of them in terms of what they
want to do right so if you have
a goal and let's take it let's make it a
little bit more
let's say uh conceptually understandable
for
for us that we're not we're not those
guys right we're not going to mars but
let's go
let's use the marathon as an example
again right so if you've set that goal
of running a marathon or whatever
the challenge is for yourself every
decision you make
either takes you closer to that goal or
further away so once you define exactly
what it is
that goal is in your life
every decision falls within the
framework of getting you closer or
further away so
it doesn't surprise me i hadn't heard
that about um about elon musk
but that doesn't surprise me at all and
that's what that's what goal setting is
all about right because if you have a
clear goal
then everything else becomes so much
more simple with with the ultras
someone would thought you want to go for
a beer tonight no
very very simple very simple to make
that because if i do that it's getting
me further away from my goal
and if you're super focused on where you
want to go and it goes back to
the micro imbalance and the macro
balance at that time
if if that decision gets you closer or
further away
it's a very easy decision to make isn't
it
what advice would you give yourself 10
years ago good question
um focus on people and what i mean by
that
is that's used across so many different
so many different ways the the any
success we've had in the agency
um over the last few years is purely
because
of the people that we have in the
business but the focus on people within
the community that we have we have we
have an outstanding internal team
culture
it's the thing that i'm most proud of
more than any other accolade of fastest
growing and
the clients we have or anything like
that it's the it's the culture we have
in the business that there's there's no
[ __ ] there's no politics
there's no backstabbing there's no
there's none of this
and we're operating in an environment
that's notorious for it
agency life is notorious for
all of the things that i just said
especially in this region so we've
created this environment where we have a
very very low staff turnover
and we focus on we focus on people over
profits and that's not just a nice thing
that
is put up on the wall but it's it's it
really is
the deciding factor of everything that
we do
and there's a number of reasons around
that
i'm personally not motivated about
chasing money it's not why i get out of
bed in the morning and and
it allows me to make decisions really
easily with regards to
okay that's going to cost us more money
but it's the right thing to do for the
people
so we just do that time and time and
time again and 10 years later
you end up with a culture where
everybody in the environment
knows exactly what's um i suppose what's
championed and what's uh you know what's
celebrated and what's
you know what's promoted within the
business and it's
it's not sales it's not bringing in a
big contract it's not it's not all of
those financial
drivers although they're important
because we're still a you know we're
still a business and you know
that has to work for everybody to be
able to come to work
but the focus is always always about
what people have done for each other
i'll give you an example we
do i do um a full agency meeting every
wednesday so i've got everybody on the
call
anywhere from 80 to 100 people on a zoom
call
and we start every single meeting with
10 minutes
we call the compliment circle so
everybody in the zoom chat
everyone in the zoom chat writes down
what they're grateful for and to whom
they're grateful
so from a work context so ah thanks so
much for jenny because
she went over and above what were you
grateful for this week can you remember
what was i grateful for this week
um for me yeah to be honest it's
literally the management of the workload
that we've got on right now
and we're in a fortunate space where we
spent 10 years building our
our digital credibility and and and
pushing the business into that space
covert is accelerated digital so you
know we're in a fortunate space that
we're very busy right now
um because we're managing all it's
changing dynamics but we're busy in that
space
and i'm incredibly grateful for the
amount of work that the team
is dealing with because we've got people
that are that are burning themselves to
the floor
that my job is to facilitate that as
much as i can hire as many
people as we can to try and depressurize
and we're a growing organism we're not
perfect like we make mistakes as a
business
but the intent is always correct
we're always trying to do the best by
our clients we're always trying to do
the best by our people internally
and because of that we're given leeway
internally our team will run through
walls for us
because they know that we're not trying
to we're not asking them to run through
the wall
because we want to make more money we're
saying that this is a scenario
how do we how do we get through this
together you know and they're putting
their hand up and like well i'll run
through that wall
oh cool okay johnny john's running
through that wall and bob's like i'm
gonna run through that wall
and because we've got this car disc this
culture internally
that's what's happening now for me
that's great firstly that's a
successful business culture internally
and it's the right thing to do because
it's the right thing from a human and
empathetic perspective
but i don't want to build a business on
on people burning themselves and running
through walls that's that's not what i
want to do because then that defeats the
purpose of
my goal which is running a human focused
empathetic
organization so my focus is right [ __ ]
okay let's focus on recruitment
we need more people in that person needs
support that person needs support that
account
the client's not paying for those extra
two people but we have to put them on it
because these guys are getting killed
here
because you know the client's that much
more demanding it's a government client
we can't really say no we're stuck in a
bit of an awkward place
throw more resource at it because yes
we'll lose money on that account perhaps
but
people will be okay and then over time
we'll work out how to
bring it back into a profitable space so
we don't run the business from a
spreadsheet
we run the business from looking at
people and saying hey what do we need to
do right by people whilst at the same
time running a good organization
and that's allowed us over the last two
years to
to win those accolades of you know
fastest growing agencies and blah blah
blah
and that's what we're trying to do it's
just it's just focus on people that's
your
going to mars that's not yeah
i really like it i think to hear
in especially this year of all years a
year where people have been made
redundant left right and center and had
job and career
challenges that focusing on people first
has been anti-fragile is a
very reassuring thing to hear yeah i
mean
that served us so well whilst
coronavirus
like just decimated everything right and
we've got it's
in terms of like how people people knew
that the company had their back
and that helped them in many many ways
we paid for professionals to come in and
do
uh mental health workshops for the team
we were sending delivery credit once a
week
to everybody in the agency so that um
so that everyone could get to deliver to
deliver their lunch and then everyone
would get on the zoo and we'd all have
team lunch together
so we honestly we didn't we did so many
things
to try and focus on on bringing everyone
together and making everyone understand
that no the company's here for you like
we as an agency well we'll get through
this together
and and that definitely helped it
definitely helped the team and as things
started to get better
economically with the business now we
were losing clients because you know
major events expo were put on hold for
example with a social media agency for
expo
i had six people on that account full
time and then they send us a letter
saying
as of next week expo 2021 now yeah but
there you go
we had a few things like that where sort
of revenues got hit
but no we didn't cut anybody's salary we
didn't let anybody go we didn't do any
of those things and we said right we're
going to pay for this we're going to
fund
this as long as we can without affecting
anybody
in the organization because that's the
right thing to do
and that's going to cost myself as a
shareholder and that's going to cost us
but it's the right thing to do from a
selfish perspective it will let me sleep
at night
to know that i'm not basically borrowing
from my team by cutting their salaries
to then keep that money here for a rainy
day we said right if we need to put all
of this back in
to keep these guys safe and that's what
we're going to do and the market
fortunately started to come
back a little bit earlier than it has
for most because we're in the digital
space
we picked up more work and then as that
happened what did the team do they start
running through walls because they saw
what we did
you know so it's not even just a i mean
it sounds like it's a good business
decision but
it wasn't that's just that was just the
payoff for doing the right thing from a
human perspective
and that's what's you know that's what's
the most important and that's why we're
where we are today we've you know we've
hired 40 people since january
and and that's because we've we've
focused on
on people and they've run through walls
we've winner we win accounts because of
that
and um it's just i'm proud to be part of
that team not to
run the company and own that company i'm
proud to be part of
that group of people where i can walk in
where everyone's high-fiving each other
and you just think [ __ ] you know what
this is a good place to be i've seen
some companies that i think you say
dictatorially try and achieve the same
thing
so i've seen some companies during my
experience
where have a
autocratic forced level of socialization
and people are walking along and they're
always they've got to high-five
everybody
when they make a sale and the whole
thing stops and stuff like that
and um i always wonder it feels a little
bit like america sorry to all of the
americans that are listening
um you know when someone's in a brand
new relationship
and all they do is post about their
relationship it's not just america
though
yeah but so i'm getting up to america
wait i haven't forgotten about the
americans
um someone's in a brand new relationship
all of their facebook photos
then they get to normal level of
facebook photos and then they start
popping back up and you think
i think there's something wrong and i
think that that is what they're holding
on to
sure and when i hear the way that people
from america who are
quite rightly proud of their country it
it's a little bit like the lady doth
protest too much it feels a bit
sort of like i really like all the time
i
love my country i miss that yeah there's
quite a lot of problems in the country
but when i see these companies
who operate in the same way it feels
incredibly forced
and realizing that the emperor isn't
wearing any clothes
happens so quickly for people like one
of the
interesting insights i learned the other
day is why we have white as humans
around our eyes
and it's so that we can see where the
other person's looking
because gaze is such an important
indicator of truthfulness interesting
if you look at all of the other primates
you look at gorillas and chimps
black eyes so you wouldn't be able to
see where someone's looking and because
truthfulness is such an important part
we have 14 million sensory cells in our
body
and 11 million of them are dedicated to
sight
same again massively massively skewed
towards what we're looking at
and my concern for companies like that
and
also for other ones who maybe don't have
this customer this uh employees
centered focus is that
if it's not there built into the source
code
emergent coming out of the day-to-day
activity
people are so quick to pick up on
hypocrisy yeah
and it's a dangerous situation to be in
hey it is and i i listened to your
podcast of the day about um
about wework as well wow yeah that was
really interesting
and that's i suppose if you're talking
about a a spectrum that's the
the furthest end of the scale where it
is forced right and it was forced and it
very much so there was a lot of
there's a lot of um yeah a lot of
hypocrisy as you say there's a lot of
um uh just talking about saving the
planet well we've got three private jets
ten holiday homes yeah exactly that sort
of thing right and it's
it is that but if we break it back down
into into a more granular level and we
talk about okay well
the culture's inside organizations and
his free lunch is going to going to do
the
do the thing is it like is it um is it
all the perks is it the you know
whatever you go into facebook oh wow
you've got a whole kitchen there you can
make your food is it all those things no
it's not
people want to feel safe that's it
like if they feel safe when they come
into work that they're not going to be
judged
they're not going to be um ostracized
for for whatever reason
they're not going to be fired because
politically it was the right thing to do
and if they feel safe coming together
they can really
bring themselves to work as humans and
that can be
anything that goes with that so we focus
on the fact that
this is something that that i speak to
every single person in an interview
about i said look if you
you've you're choosing to come and work
here and we really respect that
because you're choosing to invest your
time which is the most important
element that any of us have it's usually
invest your time in the agency you're
choosing to invest your career in this
organization
and we we're firstly very grateful for
that but we understand that this is a
two-way relationship
yes you're getting paid a salary to do
that but you're investing a huge amount
of who you
are and i know how busy the agency is so
i know
what you're going to be investing in
this and that comes from a new joiner or
existing it's the same dialogue same
conversation
so therefore as an agency we have a
responsibility not just to say
cool well at 6 00 pm class you're not
our responsibility anymore
you go and can you keep your personal
life out of this because
that's that's your life and we're only
interested in the hours that we pay you
for
that's that's not how we operate that's
how a lot of businesses operate
you should be able to come in and start
crying at work because something's
happened at home
like you have to be human in the
workplace and if if you if you create
the environment where someone can really
bring their humanity into the workplace
and so i'm having a really [ __ ] day
because of a b c or d
and when we're dealing with the size of
workforce we have we have
parents dying we have um scenarios
of someone getting terminally ill we
have
um whether that be the workforce or
their their
their sister their brother you know
there's things going on all the time
and we had a cool focus from from early
on of saying right we need to look after
them in
in in their entirety so we've like we've
gone to pick somebody up from an office
because
we've been told something has happened
in their family before they've been told
we've had to pick them up from a client
meeting with a plane ticket
and be like you need to go home and take
them to the airport
get on a plane like we have to look
after people to that level
because at the end of the day how can
how can we ask so much of people
in the workspace when i know that
they're working on weekends i know that
they'll be working the evening for that
pitch tomorrow morning
all of those things so as a company
we've made the decision that we will
look after the entirety of that person
whether that be
sometimes financially giving them like
something's going on at home will that
help
cool that'll help and and that's not
something we talk about across the
business and
from one person to the other person they
don't know that we've done it it's not
something that we celebrate
but it's something we do on an
individual level often because we'll
have someone in the office
crying their eyes out because a b c and
d and if if myself or
as a company we have the opportunity to
fix that problem
by telling that person that what do you
mean you're waiting for a week to get on
the plane because of x y and z
like absolutely no workload off money
there you go
go you know we've had scenarios where
someone's not wanting to say that
they're waiting for their salary to come
through in a week's time to get on a
plane to go and see their sick father
i was just like what they were new they
didn't know that they could actually ask
for these things
i was like there's a plane ticket not
even taking it out of your salary or if
you go
come back when you know when you're okay
one thing that i've thought about a lot
recently and this ties into it
is how athletes
and sports people have a lot of mental
models that we probably should port
across into real life
and think about what every group sport
is called the team yeah what does the
team do
team works together to achieve the goals
i think team
in a business context a lot of the time
is just a title
yeah i've been a part of teams i'm sure
you have as well where
no one cares you turn up how many people
know that i can't be myself at work i
can't say what i mean to say
yeah and the team isn't working together
you're pulling in that direction i'm
pulling in this one and john's pulling
that way and we're getting nowhere
everyone's pretending to be robots right
because everyone's bringing their work
selves to work
so that's there's a problem there
already and like you said there's
there's high performing teams and
there's certain indicators of
high-performing teams that are similar
across
all so one of the wednesday calls that i
do i
i talk through different things that i
want to pick up during the week that i
think will help the
help the organization help the team one
of them the other day was actually the
all blacks
so it's the tenants of the of the all
blacks rugby team what are they
um i can't remember all of them um but
one that certainly stands out
is no [ __ ] fine that's actually the
actual words what
what an unbelievable rule to live life
by and they're literally like doesn't
matter how good you are
if you're a [ __ ] you're not on this
team so you could be the greatest rugby
player that the world has ever seen
if you act like a [ __ ] you're gone
the other one is sweeping the sheds
so sweep the sheds it doesn't matter who
you are could be richard mccoy in this
case as the is the captain of the team
you should still be the guy that's
sweeping the changing rooms after a game
you should be able to do that and you
should do that at times so it's about
understanding that nobody's too big
nobody's bigger than the team itself
nobody's more important than the team
itself and myself included i might own
the business
but i'm their sleeves rolled up with the
team when it when it needs to that's
what that's what you need to
that's what you need to be able to do so
the way that we talk
internally is we're somewhere between a
family and a high performing team
we do more on the family side than most
companies would but
don't think that you can come come into
work day after day and not perform
because you will be asked to leave and
everyone knows that i know we've
we've moved people out of the businesses
they're just i a the only
the only thing we're ruthless on in the
company the only thing is culture
so we've had people that have come in
done a great job i'm getting whatsapp
messages from the clients saying how
happy they are with this new person
that's running their account
but they're being a [ __ ] internally
three weeks later they're gone
i phoned the client i'm sorry i know
they're really good at their job i know
you love them blah blah
but no internally they were gossiping
they were
just niggling just they're the sort of
cancer you need to pull out very quickly
before it starts to poison the well and
and that was uh
yeah that's the one thing that we that
we focus on to back that up
i remember reading an example about
putting problem students in with groups
of high performers
and what the researchers were trying to
look at was
does one bad apple spoil the lot or can
an overwhelming number of high
performers bring up the person
who is lazy or unmotivated or negative
or
transactional uh and it turned out that
it was one bad apple spoils a lot
fairly robustly across a number of
different studies amazing
they found if you put into a i think it
was
academic working like creating a
portfolio for some master's program
yeah and um you could put one
underperforming student in with a group
of five of the highest performing
students and all the high performing
students would start to down regulate
um so being
how would you say being dictatorial with
culture
and liberal with emotion yeah i think
good work
seems like a nice a nice idea
my final question is what are you
working on personally over the next year
you've still got areas of yourself that
you want to enhance and reduce
what have you got sort of on the
personal agm for the next year
yeah good question so there's a couple
of different areas so firstly um
so you know one easier area of that
question to answer
the fitness side so you know i'm
focusing on running the fastest marathon
that i can so
i'm focused on goals for that so i
changed all of my training from
some of the longer ultra stuff to trying
to run as i feel like a sprinter you
know
yeah it's a very different way of
training it's a very different mindset
it's what you're hoping to hit um my my
uh my pb at the moment is 3 14 for the
for the marathon and i want to get a sub
3.
so i've got a bit of work to do um so
yeah so we'll see if it doesn't help the
bloody races kick keep getting cancelled
have a dab you got canceled the buy got
cancelled so so we'll see so
when i get back to actually you know
being lined up for a race then that's
going to be the
the goal and outside of that look my
focus is
i'm i'm fairly newly married so it's
making sure that i'm balancing that side
of things with everything that's going
on with work because you know we're we
just opened an office in saudi we're you
know in the process of um
uh of opening in egypt so that that's
sucking up a lot of my time so it's just
trying to balance
everything i've got going on um with you
know focusing on
on the work because i need to push that
as far as i can right now it's one of
those points where
i have to go all in on it but not to the
detriment whereas before i had
girlfriends and stuff was a lot more
relaxed it's like okay
let's push that girl as it goes yeah you
know now i need to be a bigger
commitment now bigger commitment got to
be more focus so
just trying to be the best i can in that
space and and to be honest just
constantly growing you know
from from a leadership perspective every
day is a new set of challenges
every day i've never done x before
as a company grows right you know you've
never looked after 30 people before then
you've never looked after 31 before
then you've never worked after 32. so
we're getting to the stage now where
there's
what i've noticed and obviously the
business books say this but it's only
when you really
get to it you really understand that
when things get to a certain scale and
size
everything changes so the difference
between like x and y
is not a huge it's just more hours of
the same now all of a sudden my role
completely changes so i'm now further
out of my comfort zone than i was six
months ago
and exponentially exponentially and it
keeps challenging that right so i'm not
doing the stuff that
i feel i was good at so you know you
start off doing whatever x is
whatever your artistry is and you build
a business around it and then you do
more of it and more of it and more of it
and then you actually start to do less
of it
because you start to bring people in
right and then it gets to a point where
you don't do any of it
and your job is completely different
because you don't do any of these things
anymore
you your focus has to be completely it's
driving the strategy of the company
forward looking after people making sure
that resourcing
we're set up making sure that where are
the problem points where where are
things maybe falling between the gaps
and
as we're scaling so much like we grew 91
percent head count last year
so you can imagine it's a different
business
it's it's a completely different
organization and like i said we're not
we're not perfect
in in any which way we're trying to be
the best that we can be
and sometimes there's with things that
we do incredibly well and
and you know we get that visibility for
it which which
is down to amazing people in the
organization and other times we get it
wrong
and my job is to look across the
business and try and pinpoint
where we're going wrong or where we're
going down a path that's wrong or where
we've got the wrong people doing the
wrong things
so my job now is mostly resourcing of
just literally
get not not letting us put square pegs
in round holes
i need the round pegs in the round holes
and and that's if you get that right
then everything works well as soon as
you get high-performing people
doing the wrong thing they might they're
not high-performing people anymore
so you can end up losing really really
good talent because
you haven't focused on what they're
actually doing day to day and would they
be better over here so
it's a constant move because this person
is on leave and this person's sick and
then this person joins
so it's constantly evolving so being
better at that
um is my core focus so trying to consume
whatever i can to
to just improve a couple of insights
there the first one being
you were talking about your relationship
and i was thinking about the analogy
with the team
and don't that bad apple spoiled a lot
internally especially when you're
spending a lot of time with one person
all of the different dials and knobs of
emotions and resentment
and undealt with trauma that you have
are kind of like different players or
different team members
and what you don't necessarily want
actually is to set the tone early on
early on in this marriage that you've
got
with some of those bad apples actually
starting to
you know plant and get some roots in
there and then i've stopped it for a bit
and then it comes back and it's much
harder you know as we've spoken about
use the word exponential
yeah that can grow into a real big
problem so i think setting the tone in
relationships
early very positively and doubling down
on that
front loading the lack of the lack of
arguing
yeah i think or front loading the
harmony is a way that you could look at
doing that i think it's a very very
smart way to run a relationship
and the second thing was you were
talking about doing something new that
i've never done before which is imposter
syndrome
like feeling i am
unprepared unqualified and inexperienced
at all of the stuff that i have to do
every day
and i had seth godin on the show a
couple of weeks ago and he
gave this wonderful example about
imposter syndrome when he said
when you feel impostor syndrome say
thank you if you're doing something
that you've never done before you have
every right to feel like an imposter
feeling like an imposter is a sign that
you're doing good work
it means that you are breaking new
ground it means that you are doing
things pushing the boundaries of what
you have done before
so say thank you and i was like yeah
such a good way of looking at it isn't
it
i i did a whole podcast myself my
business partner on imposter syndrome
and it was one of the most downloaded
shows that we that we ever did
because everybody feels it every time
you get a new job every time you get a
promotion
uh any of these things you always feel
like there's surely there's someone more
qualified than i am
and no i've gone through it multiple
times but now
i'm going through like as i said all
these new challenges of you know where
we're at would work but
i'm totally cool with that because
the freedom i give myself and the
freedom i give my team is that it's okay
not to be great at anything like any
anyone in the on the management team can
be like i know that's within my remit
because i look after x
but i haven't got a [ __ ] clue about
that side of things because i know that
they're really good over here
and nobody's good at everything right
and you have to you have to give
yourself
you have to be easy enough on yourself
to understand that if you're going to
grow
you're you're it's growth for a reason
it's because you don't know how to do it
and it's it's it's understanding that
and i think he put it really
really well with with saying thank you
because if you have that gratitude
mindset as well
to know that okay well i'm going into
this space i should be thankful that
i've either put myself in it
so gratitude to yourself or thank you to
ex person
that believes in you enough to say that
they feel that you can do that
so you should yeah you should be
grateful for that and that's how we all
grow
i love it tom man today's been fantastic
thank you for joining me people want to
check out your stuff where should they
go
um tom houghton on instagram probably
the best one um
anything professional on linkedin as
well i know i'm on there and then um
and yeah podcast the creator sessions um
so yeah that's it
fantastic thank you
you